breaking overnight the new violence
along the Gaza Strip where the latest
exchange of gunfire between the Israelis
and Palestinians has turned deadly it
comes ahead of Israeli elections next
week and as Palestinians mark one year
of their weekly protests with a large
March at what they consider Israel's
blockade of their land
Seth Doane is in Gaza this morning Seth
good morning good morning the protests
are starting to heat up you can see
burning tires and also occasionally
Israeli forces are firing tear gas
toward these Palestinian protesters who
are allowing rocks and projectiles back
toward that fence the border with Israel
protesters are crying out against what
they call the siege of Gaza Israel has
sealed off the narrow Gaza Strip due to
security concerns and it affects nearly
every aspect of life from food to
electricity to the ability to freely
come and go around half of all Gaza pnes
are unemployed Hamas the group that runs
Gaza and is considered a terrorist
organization by Israel is behind these
protests even busing in participants but
also encouraging them to keep calm
Egyptian negotiators have been in Gaza
this week trying to broker a deal which
would offer to Palestinians better
electricity expanded fishing zones fuel
for power stations and foreign financial
aid in exchange Israel is demanding
today's protests be nonviolent and that
Palestinians stop firing rockets into
Israel Israel's military massed along
the Gaza border tensions increased this
week after Palestinians fired a rocket
into central Israel striking a house and
wounding seven Israel pounded back with
airstrikes that leveled the building
Mohamed gazali lived in a business tied
to Hamas had an office inside he's real
he's called us and said take your
children and get out of the house we're
going to demolish it he told us I said
I'm kidding
weren't and a few minutes later the
house was leveled
no one was injured in many ways today is
a test the Israelis do not want to see
violence here escalate particularly just
about a week ahead of a key national
election and Palestinians are wary of
any promises made by Israelis Michelle
all right Seth thank you